hey I'm Kristian harloff and our guest
today she is the host of Nerdist news
and the bizarre States podcast Jessica
Chobot is so where's Tiffany cuz that's
really the only reason why I showed up
I'll explain that to the logo yes we're
super excited that recipe here he
finally had talked to her but we can't
yet because our coast isn't here Tiffany
what's going on where are you Christian
I'm on my way I know this is easy driver
I'm telling you that I think would you
just say hi to my co-hosts really
quickly no that's totally what's
Ed's a pro driver enjoy the ride we'll
see you when you get here well maybe not
you look at that is that something that
would make Nerdist news
yeah possibly I mean we cover all pop
culture stuff so as long as it's in that
wheelhouse we now we know that you said
that could make Nerdist news once you
have made your other show because it's
paranormal stuff I keep asking her on
that's all kind of like just a bizarre
state as everybody has a weird story so
as long as you have a creepy weirdo
freak that story we always are looking
for gasps oh oh their shoes thank you so
much for the ride I'm not gonna
recommend you we should talk about the
weekly agent no Jessica
if you didn't know already our show is
the only show where we put our butts on
the line every way I actually do know I
watched last week for we are your
friends I think you get what hey sorry
sorry sorry I'm Oh Tiffany you bet I
believe a trillion and the estimated box
office for we are your friend
1.8 million which means we're having
such a nice time here in Seneca and you
just bring in that feet up Christian oh
you keep losing maybe you're nervous
about winning because you wouldn't know
how to emotionally handle it I agree
with you at this point we're actually
doing you a favor I don't like these two
together this week punishment comes from
a youtube user
Kyle cos M'Baye who says loser should
put gummy bears in their pants their
pinch he means in your pants really good
this is not gonna be good get out of
here so this week's weekly wager is
going to be on the box office for
transporter refueled I'm gonna say that
I think it's gonna open up at ten
million I think people are staying away
from the box office right now and it's
not Jason Statham
6 million for transporter all right you
guys if you want to get in our weekly
wager though make sure use the hashtag
loser should on YouTube in the comments
below on Twitter on Facebook because
it's definitely yet again going to be
something that probably Christian has to
do put in their hashtag loser should do
a slow dance with gina carano I know
this is the part I say today's topics
they throw things at me and it's it's
very funny so come on bring him up
headlines
I feel like we can talk a little bit
about the nerd film genre nerd him in
general is almost like MMA when I first
started out it was just about great it's
about punching and now it is like an
evolved yeah I'm very excited for like
Batman V Superman but also very very
nervous about seeing Wonder Woman in
that role because I'm really obsessed
with her and so that's where I start
going down that fan girl crazy like
there was no superhero genre as there is
today you look at a movie like we are
your friends to where you have that EDM
music right maybe that was one of the
movies that you're trying because video
games another genre hasn't done it yet
they've tried to haven't had that boom
to a comic movie I actually really enjoy
it the first Resident Evil movie
everybody else pretty much hated it I
like Raider movies - I got it was pretty
fun one was decent when you think about
what the Avengers Avengers - you didn't
like something yeah they are now we're
not a galaxy booth movies yeah
Warcraft might be the first good movie
Assassin's Creed might be but we're
talking about well you guys have got me
excited hearing you talk about games it
is time for our so this particular game
is called brains and or brawn I'm gonna
tell you guys a fictitious movie
adventure if I was to say the Lorien
time machine back to the future Tiffany
would get a point there so Tiffany I
would drop a cheese ball like that at
the very end I'm gonna throw cheese
balls up whoever gets the most cheese
balls into their mouth you could still
win so you guys ready yeah all right
translating dog collar up
telepathic swimming pool of justice
fizzy lifting drink Wow
the passive dream machine oh the
neuralyzer machine gun lake gotta get
processed Tiffany listen listen and
swoop in for the kill impressive
oh no you blew it cuz you said planet
oil slick shoes we have a winner as far
as trivia goes but now we get to the
part where you physical challenge okay
throw them up there I'll see how many
you can get in your mother okay one no
but you want to have some respect she's
like Tiffany you win twice today here's
an impression of Tiffany's no you were
not gracious to our guest cuz you won
the game and you you are going to now do
either a sea hero do on the winners we
love winning
are you ready I'm still dressed out by
there
hey Tiffany you know how it works you're
gonna get ten seconds you can rant about
whatever you want are you ready yes
please that we are your friend just came
out they're totally talking about how
they have to get out of Valley after
shredder Conger came out they're like oh
we got to get out of content that makes
sense straight out the valley I live in
the valley and I love it and I can ride
my bike to the grocery store guests
Jessica Chobot
you guys can [ __ ] her on social media at
Jessica Chobot make sure you check her
out on Nerdist news at Nerdist news and
you can find out more about bizarre
States there as well and don't forget to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
make sure that you download the Fandango
movie clips app on your smartphone and
then watch us next week on movie Freeza
okay okay yeah game sweet I hate you
gummi bears